[Music]
how is engaged life going right now
what's the wedding planning status
well it's engaged life it's going
amazing wedding planning not so much but
it's kind that when we have wedding
planners who has his heart
dark is a start nonetheless we have a
giant hurdle out of the way she said yes
so here we go what was that moment that
you realized that you wanted Nikki to be
your wife I honestly was a long time ago
I know I found the right gal and I I
didn't want to live without hey miss
auntie I know right it's crazy how's she
doing it she's doing so good she's
honestly the strongest person I know and
Bertie is just so cute she's like her
daddy she is like 100% her dad which is
so cool
pretend John's not here right now is
that giving you the itch to start a
family of your own
actually I being in with greedy and
labor for 22 hours I was like yeah I'm
fine not doing this I think I'm okay I
saw a lot and I can't unsee that
lastly we got to talk about one of the
funnest parts about getting married the
bachelor and bachelorette parties are
you guys thinking that you would do a
combo or kind of your own thing oh sure
so I guess that means I'm doing my own
thing
[Music]
you